an underclass is being created many of
us shortcoming years and years ago but
nothing was done about it and this
underclass in the bonjour in the ghettos
in the poorest suburb exists on a
mixture of welfare dependency and quite
violent criminality and how you deal
with that because we've dealt with it
basically but just shutting it off there
but although it's a serious social
problem it is not a threat to the state
embarrassment to the state it's an
expensive danger to the state because
all these businesses have to be rebuilt
but revolutions are not built on rise in
which the average age of the people
arrested is 17. the reason why Liza
venomor in 1968 were far more
significant was it wasn't just the
students who were writing in major
cities and and going for a revolution
the unions joined in the working class
joined in